true love  [Music]  that's a gift unlike any other  it's all scary until you just do it  so why not just do it  [Music]  this is your captain welcoming you to  wyman air flight 227  you remember those lessons i used to  give you you ready to give it a go  make sure that the horizon stays level  right here i'm going to turn off the  autopilot  look bruh  he's having a heart attack it's okay  we have no pilot the autopilot's broken  we have no idea where we are  neither of us can land a plane hello can  anyone hear me this is a distress  come in call is two two seven you still  got it in the air so keep doing what  you're doing  holy [ __ ] look at that i see the storm  it's too big to go around you're gonna  have to play through it  that's our shot no going back let's get  off this planet  [Music]  you